Hi.
Hi Nadia, how are you?
Fine, yeah.
It's Frank.
Yeah, I know.
Are you ready for your interview?
Yeah, if you want.
Why don't we start off the interview with you telling us a little bit about how you got s now I understand you're a do you you paint, right?
Yeah, too.
Yeah.
How did you get started with holography?
What attracted you to holography?
Well, first time I saw hologram was when I was working with uh George D Aince.
Mm-hmm.
Uh you know him?
Yes, the name.
Well, I was his uh assistant.
Yes.
And well it was kind of mysterious for me.
Um you know, this to see the treaty in space like this that you can't touch, can't even touch.
Yes.
And especially the like if uh light effect.
So I thought it would be great to try to bring that media in my work 'cause I don't only paint, I do most uh installation.
Okay.
So that's that's like uh how I I how I start.
George uh produced a C D ROM or something, didn't he?
Yeah.
It's gonna come out next month.
Next month.
Well, while I have you on the line, why don't you just take a minute to say a little bit about the C D.
It's a more like a historical look at holography, art holography, right?
Yeah, really.
It's it's more on the like it's good um pattern 'cause it got like uh four hundred artists.
Yeah.
So it's good for this, but it's like uh two or three uh work of each one.
Mm-hmm.
And it smells like past work.
Yeah.
It's not like right now 'cause I don't know, um there's some artists that it's not there.
So but the uh the answer is more classical.
Yeah, yeah.
So it's I think it's normal that that way.
What's happening with holography in Montreal?
Is there a community of holographers or no?
No.
No, what's going on?
Well there there's n like only two or three artists that work with holography.
Yeah.
So they know each other but you don't talk about community with two or three people.
Yes.
So I I don't know, maybe it's too expensive.
Well sometimes you have to have a community of two or three before you can have a community of two or three hundred.
Yeah, of course.
Yeah.
But I think that right now it's medium that artists is like kind of um I don't know say um it's difficult to work 'cause now you know it's video, it's work that you go fast and holography it's long work to get something.
Mhm.
So I don't know, maybe it's not only Montreal, it's everywhere.
I just went to New York to work.
Yeah.
And it was close the same thing up there.
Yeah, I think so, yeah.
There's not much 'cause uh You were with Anna Maria, right?
Yeah.
What did you do down there?
It was Bruno down there too?
Uh yeah, he went before me.
Yeah.
And we we did um each other or work up there.
Mhm.
So it was good 'cause we don't have full flavor.
Yeah.
Uh so we can take a body like this.
And I did like I don't know, twenty holograms.
Wow.
And maybe ten that goes on specific installation.
So I got like ten words going out now.
Wow, that's a lot of holograms to do.
How long were you there?
Uh a week.
Wow, you were working like crazy.
Yeah.
Uh well we had fun too.
Go see some exodus too.
But not in holography.
What what do you find with holography as being the most frustrating?
Mm, maybe when you work three day on one hologram and it it doesn't go.
It doesn't come.
Yeah.
So or it's sometimes just little little thing that you say no, it's not good, you know.
So it's uh really technical.
Yeah.
And I like more um I like more work with conceptual or the idea, you know.
So that's only the the only thing though 'cause in the um other end I like like only that you can touch the medium, the instrument.
Yeah.
So you you have like uh I don't know, say me and list but a talking with your work, you know.
Mm-hmm.
So and the black environment is um size.
That's okay.
Just the object lightning with the light with the light laser.
You're pretty limited.
Yeah, but for me, 'cause you work in black, it's like it gave s some importance to the object.
Yes to work with.
And the objects actually gives importance to the black, which is a way that a lot of people don't even look at it.
I f I find the space the empty space within the hologram interesting as well.
Yeah.
Um I work too with the um empty space.
Um but I was w talking about the object in on the table when you work, when you're at work and doing making it hologram.
The object lightning, it's like you have other dimension within uh you don't say m it.
Yeah.
With it.
Other thinking of the object so you can take it out of way to work with it and to do something with it.
Mm-hmm.
So do you find it frustrating to have an idea inside your mind of what it is you want to express and then you find out that holography is not able to express it.
Well, I mix a lot of media at the same time.
So if I find that holography don't do, I'm just gonna take something else, out other medium.
Yeah.
I would like video too.
And sculpture too.
So I mix all together.
Would you mix that together into one piece or would you Yeah yeah.
Um installation piece.
Mm-hmm.
So but in future what I I would like, well, it's my first work right now, is to mix performance with holography.
Okay.
That's kinda tell me a little about tell me a little about that.
Well, it's a little bit art, but you know, for me holography is like halfway virtual and halfway real.
Yeah.
So well that's the first thing why I like holography and in performance you're really there, you know.
You're it's your body the medium.
So that your body can talk with something as virtual, not only like three D uh on computer or something like this.
It's really taking place in space.
So um well I can't tell you exactly what I'm gonna do.
But it's gonna be like more I think a talking with the hologram.
With words.
Uh yeah.
Yeah.
And well words with body too.
Yeah, yeah.
Well only words can lie.
The body can't lie.
Yeah.
Nothing else can lie except words.
Um what are you doing with the school?
Are you going to be taking over the lab at the college?
Um I am right now.
No, you have you have done that now?
Yeah.
Um well at the school at the college.
Uh we call it responsible.
Okay.
Yeah.
It's like manager or something like this.
So we give courses um every week to a group that make hologram.
What is I find difficult it's to bring them to art.
'Cause I'm more like the I like science but I'm more like for art.
Yeah.
And there's no art car courses up there, so it's a little bit difficult to that way.
Will you be uh doing some of the production as well with the students?
Yeah, we only dec give that we give courses, technical courses, but for produce.
Yeah.
So that's why I was saying that the art process is not the same, so it's a little bit difficult to me to know how to bring them to do some art, you know?
Mm-hmm.
So and I I would like to them to try to integrate some hologram in the town.
Like where they want.
Yeah.
So it goes good.
You know, Bruno had mentioned uh he was thinking about w putting some exhibit together in Montreal at some point.
Has that uh been talked about anymore?
Any steps taken toward that?
Yeah, well not reading 'cause it's like more in like six or seven months 'cause we have a lot of um matrix copy to do.
Mm-hmm.
So that's a little bit long to have to do that in the same time that we we are with the student.
So but I think we we would do it like pretty soon though, this year.
How do you like the dark room work?
Do you like that?
Yeah.
Do you like did you do ever do any photography, dark room?
No.
No?
So this is your first experience in the dark room.
Yeah, I don't I don't even know how to develop f uh photograph.
Yeah.
But you can develop a hologram though, right?
Yeah, of course.
So of course, yeah.
Yeah, I guess if you're doing holograms you know how to do that.
Um I have to actually improve my interviewing skills is what I need to do.
Uh tell tell us a little bit about working in the dark room from someone who hasn't worked with photography because many many people who got get involved with holography come from photography and they just look at it as a even though it's not they look at it as sort of like an extension or another step to photography.
But uh w what are some of your experiences in the dark room as far as learning it?
Do you find it easy?
Do you find it difficult?
Do you get good results?
Well I find it's the easier part of making hologram, the dark room.
'Cause it's always the same, you know, there's not much difference.
But um what I like is that in holography you can't see the results uh before the end of the the working process.
Mm-hmm.
So you work a whole day and then you develop in the dark room and then at the end you just dry it up and you see your the light coming out.
And there's your object, there's your your work.
Well you know, there you actually can pretty much get a sense once you've been working with them for a while and you take a look at them in safe light conditions during a development process, uh you actually start to get a feel whether this is a go or a no go.
Yeah.
Very early on in the process.
But sometimes it lies a lot, you know?
It lies, yeah.
Good lies 'cause you can see like um the the black coming and then you say oh it's gonna be good, really lighting and everything and then there's some interference in it or something like that.
So just bad and then you put it in garbage and not good.
Yeah.
Well I notice there's a little bit of ghosting that takes place during the very early uh parts of the development when you put it up to the safe light if you have a good image.
And if uh the image is we don't have safe light.
There's no light at all?
No.
Well thing like furrisms but we have no safe light.
Oh, okay.
So what are your plans?
Where do you plan on taking this uh both the lab and the course over time?
Do you have any uh any steps?
Well, I don't know.
There's no um decision center here.
So I'll maybe think uh thinking about m like putting one in Montreal of only art holography art yeah.
But at first for me it's to take holography um take it out from is oh, you um it's really like um a wor uh world.
A world of of its own.
Yeah, yeah.
That's it.
It's really uh like I don't know see.
Why do you think that is?
Being someone who's getting involved with holography in the early stages uh for yourself.
Why do you think holography is so much a world unto itself?
Well, uh y did you talk to a lot of art artists that make holography?
Oh yeah, yeah, I'm I'm just talking to you now.
Yeah, I know but there there's a lot uh there's a lot of them that there are in this kind of world, you know, 'cause you're all the time in in a basement, you know, to work alone with your things.
So I don't know.
It's kind of weird feeling to work at that medium.
So I I would like to I I find that that the work now in holography it's a little bit old.
Mm-hmm.
I would like to bring it to like more actual work.
Yeah.
Like you see in some art book, you know.
You you see the work and it's a lot of different holography, it's like ten years before, you know.
Yeah, yeah.
So I'm coming up on the tw twenty years from my lab here now.
Okay.
Yeah, twenty years.
But you know what, I I find the same thing.
I mean, what is it that um you know keeps holography in the basement?
When people see holograms they become very enthusiastic.
They they they get excited about holography.
Where w why does that excitement die down?
I don't know.
I don't think it d die down, but y you know, we are in the um now it's cinema, it's the lifty, it's something fast.
Yeah, it's it's stuff that's sexy.
Holography isn't sexy right now.
Yeah.
You have it.
And it's fine, well, there's not enough color and there's not this and why it's uh it doesn't like for doing animation can take like really long.
So there's not much animation so people look at uh about more and more all the time.
Mm-hmm.
But yet still people will go and see a photography exhibit and they won't complain there's no animation in the photographs.
Maybe 'cause of the light.
It make them uh the first recognize it's T V uh more than photography.
Yeah.
Um even if the work ex i closer to photography.
Yeah photography.
That's a very good point, Nadia.
But um you know, it's like m maybe for the film, you know.
Uh nobody makes animation no more.
Like traditional animation.
You take your little thing and then you do one shot at and holography it's more like this, you know, it's really it's slow working, so I don't know m but we have to find other way to bring people to like it.
Mm-hmm.
But they don't they don't see how slow it is.
They they only see the end result and still we have holography in the position that sometimes it seems like it's in.
Yeah, of course, but I think we have to be in or like we are in two thousand two, so we have to be there and if people doesn't want this, they want something else and I think that conceptual can take it.
You know, the um if the image doesn't take people no more, you can have the ideas behind that's gonna be great, you know, and then people gonna do like well, I can think more with this kind of work.
Yeah.
I know.
It's like a balance.
Yeah, so so part of your attraction wasn't the holograms per se, it was the potential that was there for the holograms that attracted you.
The what?
The potential, you know what holography could be.
Yeah well like I s say before for me it was really that half virtual and half reality that you don't know, you know.
I don't even know in my life what's reality and what's virtual anymore.
Yeah, well that's why.
That's why holography is like a kind of image of this uh of this feeling that everybody has, you know, doesn't know if they walk for real, you know.
Yeah.
So I don't know, it's represent good the real feeling inside, so that's why I like 'em.
Okay.
Anything that you'd like to close off the show with?
Any announcements about the lab.
Now you're going to be teaching there.
How often do you work there?
Uh three days a um three days a week.
Are you there all day?
Yeah.
Well, plus the time I'm there for my homework.
I see.
Okay.
That's good.
Um anything that you wanna add?
Well only that I like uh I would like to find some holography artists and that work with holography for do as well heart.
Mm-hmm.
So you'd like to correspond with them?
Yeah, of course.
Yeah.
That would be great.
And uh I hope whoever is listening to this in I hope someone contacts you and says Hi, I'm so and so what's up?
Yeah cool.
You know?
But that doesn't always happen.
I mean uh holography really I mean everyone's been very open with this radio show that I've had now for five years.
Uh everyone speaks freely, they come on the show and they talk about their work.
And I I have noticed that um there is a community of holography out there of holographers you know and I guess maybe holography makes it be that way because it takes so much of your time, so much of your effort and so much of your energy.
Would be really great 'cause I do like social art and um engage.
Yeah.
Politically engaged.
So even if you work like alone you can be with with the community, with everyone.
Yeah.
Well I hope someone contacts you.
Thank you.
And uh good luck with your work.
All right.
Okay, thank you.
Well I'll let you know when the interview goes up and then you can do you have real audio on your computer?
Yeah.
Okay, well then you can listen to it.
Okay.
All right?
Yeah.
Anything else you want to add?
No, thank you.
Alright, will you have a good night?
Yeah.
And I'll talk to you soon.
Okay.
Bye